un triunfo de la verdad y de la justicia
así es como los abogados de johnny depp
calificaron la decisión de un jurado de
virginia que determinó que la actriz
amber hearn difamó a su ex esposo al
acusarlo de violencia doméstica dando
así fin a un mediático juicio que duró
seis semanas
y nuestro sistema judicial se basa en el
derecho de cada persona que se escuche
de su caso y nos sentimos honrados
verdaderamente honrados de ayudar al
señor de para garantizar que su caso se
considerara de forma justa a lo largo
del juicio también estamos muy
satisfechos de que el juicio haya
resonado para tantas personas del
público que valoran la verdad y la
justicia
ahora que el jurado ha llegado a su
veredicto concluyente es hora de pasar
página y mirar al futuro
pero antes de que este capítulo pase al
olvido el jurado ordenó también a johnny
depp desembolsar dos millones de dólares
a la actriz por daños y prejuicios
mientras que tendrá que pagarle al
protagonista de piratas del caribe más
de 10 millones de dólares un veredicto
que la actriz consideró como uno proceso
para los derechos de las mujeres estoy
aún más decepcionada por lo que este
veredicto significa para las mujeres es
un retroceso retrocede a una época en la
que una mujer que hablaba y denunciaba
podría ser avergonzada y humillada
públicamente
retrocede a la idea de que la violencia
contra las mujeres debe ser tomada en
serio
demandó a heart por 50 millones de
dólares y argumentó que lo difamó cuando
se llamó a sí misma una figura pública
que representa el abuso doméstico en un
artículo de opinión publicado en the
washington post en el que no nombraba a
depp pero que la actor asegura le trajo
graves consecuencias la actriz reaccionó
poniendo una contrademanda a su ex
marido por un valor de 100 millones de
dólares en el juicio que fue televisado
y seguido por millones de personas
alrededor del mundo tanto depp como
heart revelaron detalles íntimos de su
vida en pareja y ambos detallaron
situaciones de abuso durante su relación